the start of the oscar-winning film the  artist has been honored with a place on  hollywood walk of fame no not John  dujardin but Aggie the dog he's become  the first-ever canines have his paw  print cemented in history on the  boulevard sadly we're unlikely to see  ugly making any more big screen  appearances as he has officially  announced his retirement see you laughed  me you'll have to me for speaking to a  dog whisperer and now you're just  announcing that a dog has announced his  retirement you see you didn't question  that no i didn't i surprised that lassie  hasn't got his paw prints on the Walk of  Fame right why is he says it's augie the  first dr. beetle have this paw prints on  there's a lot of lassies no yeah  actually they've Hollywood boulevards  probably not long enough for the lusty  paw prints really and dogs do that by  mistake anyway don't think yesterday  could be worse could be more than the  paw print thanks